so we've been covering Donald Trump's
election of Judge Brett Kavanaugh to
replace Supreme Court Justice Anthony
Kennedy and we talked yesterday about
how immediately upon his selection there
started to be sort of a propaganda war
fought on Wikipedia around what his
position is on Roe vs. Wade and on
abortion rights and there has been a
sort of counter reaction from some
including people emailing me saying you
know David it's not going to be as bad
as we think it is when it comes to roe v
wade it's not likely roe v wade will
actually be repealed just because Brett
Kavanaugh is on the court and then
others saying you know it doesn't really
matter whether roe v wade is repealed
there's other ways that Brett
Cavanaugh's presence on the court will
de facto attack abortion rights and I
think that this sort of goes to the most
important analysis that we can do about
Brett Kavanaugh which is not so much
figuring out exactly what he meant when
he had his federal judgeship
confirmation hearings or even looking at
what are the ways in which Wikipedia the
Wikipedia article about him has been
modified 20 times when it comes to his
position on abortion the question is
let's think about how replacing Anthony
Kennedy with Brett Kavanaugh in general
is going to change the breakup of the
court right let's see if we can make an
assessment about that because the
balance and the way in which the court
will more generally approach issues of
corporate power religious liberties
individual rights and so on that's
really what's important more so than
exactly how Brett Cavanaugh would feel
if case a B C or D came before him on
the court so question one is how does
replacing Kennedy with Kavanagh change
the balance of the court
if you imagine a sort of political
spectrum from left to right progressive
to conservative on which we place the
nine Supreme Court justices let's
actually look at what the balance would
be if we were to replace Kennedy with
Cavanaugh and the New York Times
actually had a graphic that is exactly
this which they created when Neil
Gorsuch was selected on the assumption
that Gore such would be appointed which
he ultimately was we've got a spectrum
from left to right where you've got Ruth
Bader Ginsburg at the
furthest left of the court and Clarence
Thomas at the furthest right of the
court and you see Anthony Kennedy more
to the left than Center but importantly
he's guy number five in other words
there's four people to the left of
Anthony Kennedy and there's four people
to the right of Anthony Kennedy and what
is it that doesn't know and this graph
actually still includes Antonin Scalia
who is of course not not on the court
anymore so of the current justices for
the look to the left four to the right
the assessments of Brett Kavanaugh are
that he would be to the right of most of
the court but slightly to the left of
Clarence Thomas so I've actually drawn
in a vertical arrow sort of placing
Brett Kavanaugh on this political
spectrum to the right of Neil Gorsuch
but to the left of Clarence Thomas the
average of the court is going to move to
the right right the mean of where the
court is politically is going to move to
the right because you are moving from
Anthony Kennedy to the vertical arrow on
this graph which is where Brett
Kavanaugh would be what does this mean
this means that John Roberts who I have
put in a blue square on this image John
Roberts becomes the justice who is in
the middle so to speak with four
justices to the left and four justices
to the right that is a real change okay
when the swing vote when the most
centrist vote is John Roberts rather
than Anthony Kennedy not only does the
court move to the right but you can
start to think about how the divided
cases would go how would the 5-4
decisions go when you look at how
Roberts has decided on lots of 5-4
decisions in the past and you realize
that replacing Kennedy with Cavanaugh
means that this becomes a more
pro-corporate Supreme Court that this
becomes a more so-called Pro religious
liberties Supreme Court so the abortion
topic it's an important topic and we'll
have to see how quickly abortion rights
are attacked but what we know is that
with Roberts becoming the swing and
Cavanaugh being
slightly to the left of Clarence Thomas
this becomes a decidedly even more
pro-corporate
court and the Supreme Court is known for
that the supreme court generally decides
big-picture all else being equal for the
party with more power or for the
corporation however you want to sort of
divvy it up that's going to become even
worse with this move and that's much
more important than will roe v-- wade be
repealed yeah and that's why in some
respects this is even worse than Neal
Gorsuch going on to the Supreme Court
because with Gorsuch you were just
replacing a far right winger in Antonin
Scalia with a far right winger and gore
said correct now you're replacing a
centrist Anthony Kennedy with someone
who's on the far right the only thing
worse than that would be if you know
Ruth Bader Ginsburg Estonia MS Sotomayor
retired for some reason and yes was
replaced with the right winger but it's
really bad this is the only worse
scenario would be if someone like Ruth
Bader Ginsburg or Sotomayor were to
leave the court while Donald Trump is
president now relevant to this
particular president and who knows how
many years this will be important for it
could be many there's the question of
Bret Cavanaugh's views on the
investigation of presidents and whether
this played a role or not in Donald
Trump's election we don't know
particularly because it turns out that
Anthony Kennedy was actually involved in
the selection of Bret Cavanaugh which
we'll talk about a little bit next
Cavanaugh was part of an investigation
of Bill Clinton in the 1990s he worked
for ken starr's independent
investigation of Bill Clinton but now
Brett Kavanaugh believes that not only
can you not indict a sitting president
that you shouldn't even really burden a
sitting president with an investigation
and when you ask isn't that a double
standard because he was part of an
investigation of a president and now he
says you shouldn't investigate
presidents Cavanaugh says he regrets his
role in the Ken Starr investigation of
Bill Clinton that could prove hugely
relevant to Donald Trump if there are
issues related to Trump's possible
crimes visa vie the Robert Moeller
investigation if those issues get to the
Supreme Court the fact that Brett
Kavanaugh doesn't even think presidents
should be burdened by investigations
could very quickly become
now let's deal with the roe v wade and
the abortion issue I've had another 24
hours to research this and think about
it I'm more convinced than I was
yesterday that it's possible that roe v
wade might go under this court Kavanaugh
would be on the court for a very long
time but I don't think it's gonna be the
immediate threat to abortion it's too
much of a hot-button issue to straight
up
reverse roe v wade and the more likely
scenario is that abortion will suffer a
sort of death by a thousand cuts with
little restrictions coming out of the
states upheld and approved by the
Supreme Court and as Jeffrey Toobin said
we could defacto get to a dozen and a
half states with abortion bans or
effective abortion bans practically
speaking abortion bans within a couple
of years of this confirmation if it
indeed happens and I think that you know
case in point there's a handful of
states that already make it incredibly
difficult to get a safe and legal
abortion and we have roe v wade so you
can expand abortion rights or restrict
abortion rights without actually
touching roe v wade merely with the
supreme court making certain decisions
when it comes to state attempts to
curtail abortion rights and more than
likely John Roberts the Chief Justice
and the guy who will be the newfound
swing vote he and other conservatives
understand that if you overturn roe v
wade it attracts a ton of attention it
doesn't immediately change anything
because you still actually need
individual states to make decisions
about what they want the law to be when
it comes to abortion if you quietly
continually uphold small restrictions in
Texas this other restriction in Arkansas
whatever that can restrict abortion
significantly without the headline of
roe v wade overturned gay marriage is
sort of under the same lines gay
marriage has been mentioned as well as
are we going to see a reversal of the
Supreme Court's decision that states
can't ban same-sex marriage I don't
think you're gonna see that anytime soon
because Chief Justice Roberts we know is
concerned with sort of his legacy as
chief justice of the Supreme Court
he knows it wouldn't look good for a
court to make one decision in 2015 and
then in 2018 or 2019 very soon
thereafter make a decision that is the
exact opposite of that he knows that but
the new Avenue is religious freedom to
justify or defend discrimination against
LGBT individuals so I think if you're
going to see a tax on LGBT rights and
you may well see them it's not going to
be just overturning the ban on States
banning same-sex marriage it's going to
be this new wave of anti LGBT activism
which is so-called religious freedom
whatever you want to make as a micro
analysis the macro analysis is that this
is a huge conservative victory whether
Trump is a conservative or just played
one on TV to win the GOP primary doesn't
matter because this is going to be the
biggest real sustaining influence of
Trump by Trump on the United States and
then it comes to can we do anything to
stop it
and I got a few emails from people
saying you know it's a risk for
Democrats to obstruct if they're even
able to because they might suffer during
the midterms I don't know about that and
anecdotally we put a poll up on the
community tab on the David Pakman show
YouTube channel asking should Senate
Democrats obstruct the Supreme Court
pick now the reaction is of course from
our mostly left-wing audience and the
mostly left-wing audience overwhelmingly
thinks that yes
on the basis of how Republicans treated
Merrick garland or at least on the basis
of waiting until voters have had their
say at the midterms 89% of our audience
thinks that Senate Democrats should
obstruct the SCOTUS pick from Donald
Trump so I get that it's just our
audience but the bigger picture Pat is
that it doesn't seem Democrats will be
punished by voters if they get in the
way of this if they can and we don't
know whether they'll be able to yeah I
think Democrats should be able to do
whatever they can right and they should
you have that option at their hands but
they don't really have the votes they
don't that's really the problem here and
you know Republicans got away with
stealing one Supreme Court pick they'll
get away with this one as well more than
it's out of our hands it's not like the
court has to listen to public opinion
these
we'll be on the court for thirty years
or so we do the caveat would be if you
get a couple Republicans to go the other
way but at the same time if someone like
Joe Manchin is going to just support
Cavanaugh anyway you sort of zero that
out so we'll continue to talk about that